Hello there!
Now, sometimes when we're
recording "The Slow Mo Guys,"
we perform the experiment --
Before we perform the intro.
You guessed it, this
is one of those times.
Yeah.
Can't really hide the fact
that Dan has already got
himself covered in cornstarch.
Dan, what're we doing
with this little torch?
So, basically I'm gonna
try fire breathing today,
and see what that looks like in slow mo.
It'll be pretty badass, I think.
Yeah, so I'm gonna sort of--
Like that.
Whoa, I felt the heat on that.
That was good.
All right, let's see what
it looks like in slow mo!
Can I have some water, please?
Yeah.
All right, so what is our fuel of choice?
'kay, today we've got some cornstarch.
This is what I'd go for,
because it's sort of
safer than using kerosene.
Cause it's not, like,
inherently flammable.
Dan is not a professional,
so we didn't wanna put
flammable liquid in his gob.
Yeah, I've never done it before.
So, basically what I'm gonna do
is jam as much cornstarch into my mouth
as I possibly can,
and then sort of blow
it out in a fine powder,
and then it'll deflagrate
by burning the next layer of material
and just sort of create a
big fireball, hopefully.
Have you noticed that pretty much anything
in powder form is flammable?
Yeah.
Sweet, innit?
Yeah, just cause--
Even flour.
It's easily burnable, and
so that's what it does.
It just heats up the
next layer of material
and just burns it, cause it's so fine.
All right, lets bung some in.
Cool.
How's it taste?
It looked like a bloody
explosion in space,
with stuff flying out of it.
Huh.
Lookit, there's your face shot.
Oh, nice. When I was, like--
That looks badass!
That is cool!
That's cool.
What's it taste like?
Like... corn tacos or burritos.
Like a tortilla.
Yeah, like a tortilla.
Tastes like a tortilla.
All right, solid video.
Flames look good.
Dan, you don't look good.
You are absolutely caked in cornstarch.
I think it's a good look for me.
Yeah.
Follow us on Twitter if you want.
Buy the shirts, if you want.
Maybe just sit there if you want,
and don't do anything.
Just watch the videos and that.
Do whatever you want.
Whatever feels right.
See you in the next one.
That didn't look as good.
Didn't look as impressive.
No.
All right.
This video was sponsored by Audible.com,
and if you would like a free
audiobook when you sign up,
you can use this link.
There's over 150,000 books to choose from.
I haven't listened to them all yet.
It's gonna take some time.
This week, I recommend "The Hobbit,"
because the last movie just came out,
and it's the perfect time to listen
to "The Hobbit," in my opinion.
You can speed it up or
slow it down as well,
depending on how fast you listen.
It's pretty neat.
All right, that's it.
Thanks for watching, bye!